When I was growing up, girls just didn't run in public.
No one on my all boys team would pass to me.
Dad told me I couldn't be a boxer, he said I was too small.
There was a guy who tried to spit on me and then pushed me out of his way.
There comes a point where you have to be sure of yourself.
People aren't used to women being so passionate.
It scares them.
One day, I just said it doesn't matter what other people think.
I'm a fashion model who can dunk.
I'm a girl.
That doesn't mean I have to wear a skirt.
It doesn't mean I can't get all fired up.
They used to say that girl is crazy.
But then, I just kept winning.
I didn't set out to dominate, I just did.
Somebody has got to be the best.
So why not me?
I'm 55 years old and I run close to 70 miles a week.
I never felt like quitting.
There's something telling me to do it every single day.
Just want to play ball.